we're all equal you don't have to worry  about we are all equal or you treat  everybody equally both of them are wrong  here's why number one we're not all  equal when i first came up in sales and  i'm competing against the other guys  the other guy was not equal with me when  it comes down to skill set he's here i'm  here the other guy is not equal when it  comes down to strategies he's here i'm  here the other guy and i competing we're  not equal he has a referral database of  500 clients he sold memberships to i got  zero the only place that we can be equal  and is what work ethic it's the only  place the only place we can be equal in  is who's improving faster today that's  the only level playing field not  expertise not database not market not  skill set we are not equal in that area